If you carefully inspect the exit selection,
you'll notice here that item 17 happens to be missing.
It jumps from 16 to 18.
And here I'm re-running the SVG select all code.
On just circles to see all the circles, and what they're bound to.
Scrolling down we can see here item 17 happens to
correspond to a circle that has data with key 1930.
So as you can see, since we're updating the year 1930.
And we're binding the filtered year, which only corresponds to 1930.
The exit selection is everything that doesn't belong on the page.
Basically, every circle except year 1930.
And in this binding we simply tell d3 to
update year 1930 in case any of the data that was bound to it has changed.